大家好
十八分鐘，計緊時，好緊張
（笑聲）
我 overtime 好犀利架
咁呀多謝邀請先啦
不過我今朝一路練呢就練咗十六分鐘
咁所以我宜家特登講啲廢話
（笑聲）
咁第二件事呢我…
我想講好快嘅啫，啫係唔係好得
就係其實你哋好幸福，唔係因為我嚟
而係因為依度佢 train 咗啲 speaker
有啲 local 係一個月去講十八分鐘嘢
你哋知唔知架？
大家應該畀啲掌聲依度呀真係
真係
（掌聲）
依個可能係我最好嘅說話架啦
依個十八分鐘
Okay 咁我開始嘞
咁呀多謝你哋啦
好。襟一襟先
咁我係 SK ，公司係 AllRightsReserved
咁呀香港嚟架啦
咁我做好多唔同嘅創意嘅方案啦
咁佢哋叫我得閒
行下呢邊、行下嗰邊嘅。吓
咁呢好多古靈精怪嘅嘢
我都會諗、會做啦
因我鍾意嗰樣嘢
我哋大家都好熱愛創作
咁呀依個 project 可能大家都有睇過啦
上年嚟過馬來西亞嘅
咁呀…
我好鍾意呢張相。吓
咁呀今年去過韓國
依個唔係我個 project 嚟架
依個係示威嚟架
（笑聲）
吓。咁呀大家都唔好以為係光棍節
光棍節你知唔知係咩呀？
知呀嘛。吓
有冇去 shopping 呀？
冇啊大家以為光棍節
我琴晚諗梗有冇講光棍節，冇呀
咁其實真係一個示威
喺 2011 年發生咗一件好大件事
咁就係香港好多人去示威
去 complain 呢一個 brand
話點解我哋唔俾影相
你第二啲人可以俾影相
發生咗咩事
你個自尊心俾人侵犯咗
都好犀利架啦，11 年
咁呀 No D& 乜呀，有個相機喺嗰度嘅
咁樣啦
咁呀發生呢件事大家都好沮喪
同埋喺我哋呢個 generation 啦
唔識點應付
啫唔知點算好依啲事
咁呀，咁我通常都係…
啫香港有個講法就係剝花生啦
睇下咁點算啦
又唔知做乜
咁然之後呢
我喺網上嗰度睇睇睇睇睇
去到一個無奈嘅情況出現咗
無奈到係啲人講話
用叮噹啲法寶咪搞掂囉
咁呀諗下有啲隨意門啦、時光機呀
係咪真係解決得到呢？我都唔知
但好多人鍾意喎原來
好多人冒認話係啦、搞掂啦
咁我呀喺冇耐之後好快
咁啲人就收到個電話
就係日本嘅多啦 A 夢嘅
版權持有嘅公司打畀我
話要嚟香港搵我
話我有冇興趣去做
一個多啦 A 夢嘅 project
佢話因為多啦 A 夢呢
原來係 2112 年誕生架
仲有一百年前就係下年啦
我話一百年？
咁呀都好似條橋 Okay 喎我覺得
咁同埋我覺得好多香港人都好鍾意叮噹
你哋叫叮噹定多啦 A 夢架？
吓。咁話叮噹啦大家繼續
咁呀好多人鍾意叮噹
咁咪…咁我覺得，咦好似有得諗喎
同埋下年又係喎
咁呢，我喺度諗
不如同個商場嘅管理層傾下偈
將依一個咁有趣嘅意思嘅嘢帶嚟香港
啫我哋香港自己造啦，可唔可以呢？
咁我覺得個條件就有幾樣嘢嘅
佢本身有個地方喺…
你哋去過香港架啦
有個平台叫五支旗桿
五支旗桿知唔知係咩嚟架？
知唔知呀？
即不見不散呀嘛
咁然之後呢
我哋做過好多成功嘅 case 啦
有件咁嘅事啦
應該加加埋埋我覺得係 work 架嘞
咁咪同佢哋傾啦
同埋加上好多地方做啲嘢啦
做啲嘢，咁好啲啦
咁呀得出嚟個反應佢話
不如你哋去做返 Hello Kitty 啦
因為成功呀嘛
咁呀好慶幸地最嬲尾呢
我哋係得到嘅呢就係佢哋嘅信任
同埋日本嘅版權持有人嘅一齊合資
發生咗依一個 project
咁依個 project 就係
我哋去將一百隻多啦 A 夢
每一隻多啦 A 夢扐住
一件唔同嘅法寶
咁就去做依一個展覧
希望帶畀大家有一個嘅
最大嘅香港人嘅集體回憶
（你睇多啦 A 夢嚟啦！）
（誕生前 100 年祭）
（2012 年 8 月 14 日至 9 月 16 日）
（尖沙咀嘅海港城）
（香港史上最大規模嘅
多啦 A 夢展覧）
唔夠時間啦因為
（笑聲）
咁呢，然之後呢，我哋就透…
因嗰陣時好多 social media 嘅開始呀
我哋透過 social media…
咁多啦 A 夢當然唔會畀法寶你啦
有話聲我知吖
咁我就透過 social media 依樣嘢呢
就話畀人知去關心多啲唔同嘅人
因為原來當依件事一開始嗰時
大家真係好鍾意
咁我哋就透過譬如人結婚
我哋就喺度送個祝福畀佢哋啦
香港嗰陣時發生咗一件海嘅事
好多膠樽或者好多污喺個海嗰度
咁我哋用多啦 A 夢
透過依個網上嘅 social media 嘅平台
去叫人執，幫手去叫啲義工去執膠樽
我哋盡量去件事唔係叫
去關心多啲個社會
係同一般做法好奇怪嘅
但係又畀我做喎
咁呀做啦
咁甚至乎呢，香港嘅市民係好關心
原來當期時話︰
「咦！打風落雨喎！
咁會唔會啲多啦 A 夢會整親呢？」
咁好多人會睇住佢喎
新聞報導都有講
咁呀跟著呢
我哋呀甚至乎會做一啲乜呢？
就係話有一啲人呢因為…
坦白講，咁唔係好多人都係好多人識架嘛
咁好多後生仔、年輕嘅人
佢哋去嗰度表演呀
因為想多啲人聽到佢首歌
咁我哋透過呢個媒體
去畀人知道、認識下依一班人
依啲喺我哋平台度
唔係剩係講梗自己嘅嘢
係講梗大家嘅嘢
我哋覺得大家係好緊要依件事
咁呀甚至乎有啲夜晚
啫係展覧完之後
要 touch up 嗰啲公仔
嗰啲嘅藍領我哋都會關心緊
嗰個社區嘅人
咁呀，好好幸運地
好多人嚟關心返我哋
依個故仔講乜呢？我哋睇住個 mon
咁樣大家睇到「100」
個 logo 架其實
嗰「100」個 logo 其實係眼鏡嚟
咁呢，其實一百年前呢
個故仔喺…
當佢生日嗰日係 9 月 3 號嗰日呢
我哋就將依一個 concept 係真係
好徹徹底底話畀大家知
就係一百年前呢…
一百年後呢
冇人會睇到一百年後會發生咩事
因為呢，人好多時
睇唔到未來而感到不安
亦都因為依樣嘢去沮喪
咁為咗睇到未來架呢…
其實依一種…
啫用依個嘅所謂
透視未來眼鏡嘅象徵呢
其實就係一種好奇心
係推動大家去前進同埋最大嘅原動力
啫希望有多啦 A 夢嘅世界
係人人期待嘅美好未來
無論係今日、明日、十年後、一百年後
大家都為追求未來而努力
咁依個展覧好心有好報
咁呀去咗十六個城市
馬來西亞好似嚟過架
吓。但好似收錢嘅
（笑聲）
唔關我事
咁我學識咩叫正能量
其實好毛管戙棟架
你哋有冇毛管戙正能量呢一個字？
戙呢，就係因為你冇付出過囉
（笑聲）
Okay 繼續
咁呀下一個 project 嘞
好啦
咁呢，依個 project 係乜呢？
其實就係我哋發覺維多利亞港
除咗放煙花之外呢
你哋有冇特登嚟香港睇放煙花？我想知
有呀，冇呀嘛
唉。你發覺聽到依句就好啦
冇呀嘛
你哋會唔會去睇隻鴨嚟個時？
有幾聲都多過佢啦
（笑聲）
咁吖 anyway，個 point 呢就係
當其時我哋覺得維多利亞港
係咪香港依個城市
係咪可以做多啲唔同嘅嘢呢
除咗放煙花之外？
當然佢仲有好多嘢做嘅
咁我哋就想延續咗多啦 A 夢
依個 so-called 正能量嘅 project
去繼續去做一啲可能性爲依個城市
咁吖好幸運地我哋又做到啦
咁我先講一講依個故仔先
依一個故仔呢就係 2007 呢
依隻鴨唔係我發明架
喺 2007 年呢
係一個 artist 叫霍夫曼嘅人呢
就想做一個全世界最 cute 嘅鴨
咁然之後呢就去每個世界各地嗰度
啫環遊世界一周
咁佢遇過嘅經歷呢係十分之悽慘嘅
例如 2007 年就一開波就俾人射爆咗
吓。因為啲人好憎佢
咁吖好多事發生過架喎
總之就依隻鴨都幾落樸嘅
咁呀甚至乎去到 2013 年呢
喺我 before 我哋五月做之前嘅一月呢
有一晚我開電視睇到
依個《阿叻遊世界》旅遊節目
去咗 Sydney 之後呢
佢講嘅對白就係話︰
「Mr. Darling is 佢嘅姓氏。
不過我知道他嘅姓氏來源。
開玩笑知道達令港嘅來由嗎？
這是悉尼有名的達令港。」
但隻鴨喺度、喺後面一路冇人架喎
咁我發覺︰咦。我哋係咪捉蟲呢？
最嬲尾我哋係有千幾個報導
傳媒話有八百萬人
香港得七百萬人架咋
我都唔知邊度嚟…（掌聲）
嘅一個展覧
當然中間好多…因為得十八分鐘呢
我就唔會講畀你知點解會咁嘞
吓。咁吖總之呢
件事就好多人付出咗好多事
去成就依一件事
咁好多人為因素啦
講下啲笑話啦
爭住影先啦
爬上去啦，搞到我好麻煩啦
跟住有好多翻版鴨啦
（笑聲）
吓。依度有冇翻版啦？
有冇吖？
我琴日聽講話唔知好似話
你哋有個政府部門想搞
不過真係好彩冇搞，會爆我話你知
咁呢誰都以為呢依隻鴨呢
就充咗氣丟落海就得嘞
世事邊有咁簡單呀
你睇下嗰啲山寨鴨俾浪花
牽一牽就爆咗啦
依個係我個 production 嘅
manager 講嘅
吓。我每次 present 都要講一次因為
咁其實我嘅結論話你知贏嘅原因呢
依件事好成功嘅原因呢係因為童心
同埋第二樣嘢係乜呢？
就係一個地標
我哋學識依個城市原來
佢個發揮佢個潛在力有幾大
我哋日日去嘅地方有好多時我哋忽略咗
第三個啦，I am Here
就唔係講我嚟咗馬來西亞嘅故仔
得一日啫
I am Here 係乜呢？
依次呢我哋就喺個城市
喺個 landmark 入邊
去 create 個 symbol
咁我去到…我被委託去咗成都
一個叫做 Panda City 嘅地方
咁吖叫我去睇下依個地方
依一個紅升爐依一個咁大嘅一個項目
啫又商場吖，又寫字樓吖，又吖酒店呀
乜都有架嘞
同埋笪地最貴，啫好似香港中環咁啦
可以做啲乜
咁我去到之後呢
Wow！好多熊貓呀
周街都係我話你知
多到…你睇唔睇到
依架啫叫好多熊貓嗰架
睇唔睇到？睇唔到。睇到喎。好多熊貓
依度暗咗。吓
咁吖 anyway，咁呀好多熊貓總之就
咁我就開會吖，同佢哋提議就話
佢問我︰「咁你諗到啲乜吖？」咁樣
我話做熊貓啦
咁當然大家想走啦，吓
（笑聲）
咁其實我個 point 就係話
問題唔係喺熊貓
問題係點樣做到最好嗰樣嘢
將嗰個文化嘅特色帶到出嚟
依個係佢嘅特產，啫特色嗰樣嘢嚟架
我哋唔好忘記
好多時我哋好多時會忘記
想撇甩一啲嘢，覺得佢老土嗰嘢
咁我就畀咗兩個方案佢
一個就攬住碌竹，喺門口（笑聲）
一個就爬去咗上去（笑聲）
咁呀睇咗之後你揀邊個吖？
嗱，我仲有四分鐘咋
快啲揀，快啲揀
爬上去吖做死你呀
（笑聲）
咁呀梗係我都係想爬上去啦
咁所以先叫 I am Here 嘛
咁呀因為熟熊貓嘅人都知呢
通常都係複姓嘅︰
盈盈、樂樂、安安、佳佳
馬來西亞嗰兩隻叫咩名吖？
Okay 得啦 （笑聲）
咁呀總之呢
依個我就叫 I am Here 啦三個字
英文就唔止三個字添
Okay 最嬲尾，我哋係成功掛咗上去
十三噸（掌聲）
十五米大
咁吖喺依個地標入邊
我哋 create 咗個 symbol
係話畀大家知
無論個城市發展到幾蓬勃都好
有一啲嘅特色我哋唔冇忘記
我哋與時並進
而唔係遺忘咗我哋應該擁有嘅特色
我仲有三分鐘剩
我喺下邊架，細細粒
好危險架依張相影嗰時
但一定要影啦
（掌聲）
最後呢，我想講就係依一句啦
Here is the world.
Beautiful and terrible things
will happen.
Don’t be afraid.
我仲有一分鐘影張 selfie 都得
（笑聲）
（掌聲）
Thank you 咁多位